Heather McDonald is the author of when
race Trump's Merit how the pursuit of
equity sacrifices Excellence destroys
Beauty and threatens lives that book is
out today Heather McDonald
congratulations on that book and bless
you for pointing out that it destroys
Beauty which some people still care
about thank heaven so it does seem like
these outbreaks of lawlessness and MOB
rule are the easiest kinds of crimes to
stop
well that would depend on being
believing in the police Authority and
the elites have done everything they can
possibly do to discredit legitimate
police Authority by calling it racist we
are seeing civilization break down in
front of our eyes it's a willed and
voluntary breakdown and it will continue
and worsen until we stand up against the
phony charge of racism whether directed
at the police at medicine or the Arts
and start defending America's
civilizational inheritance I I love this
idea that what we're seeing is the
product of starvation or deprivation or
poverty these mobs are all organized on
social media the participants all have
smartphones that's not my idea of
starvation or deprivation
what I you wonder though I mean if
you're the opposite the so-called
opposition party which of course most of
the time colludes with the Democratic
party but if you're an ambitious
Republican like running on making the
country safe and clean and getting the
junkies out of the parks and the
marauding teenagers out of 7-Eleven like
that's not hard why does nobody do that
is everybody's so intimidated that no
one will just say that obvious truth
yes they're absolutely intimidated
because the left will say they're
playing the race card it's very odd
because the left says there's no racial
disparities in crime and yet if somebody
talks about crime they'll be accused
Soto voce of being racist so the left
actually knows something that is not
letting on the fact is is that law
enforcement is not racist for having a
disparate impact on black criminals it
has a disparate impact on black
criminals when it's enforced in a
colorblind manner because the black
crime rate is so high who suffers from
that black crime rate overwhelmingly
black victims and yet we're not allowed
to talk about those black victims
because doing so means talking about
black crime and America turns its eyes
away from the pathological inner city
culture that gives us these mobs that
gives us these barbaric drive-by
shootings and that will
tear down everything unless we stop
capitulating to the racial hustle Tucker
you see a video like that and you really
feel like wow it's not just coming it's
here and we do need to stand up against
it if you if you care about
civilization
um Heather McDonald sure appreciate your
coming on thank you for writing this
book I'm going to read it
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight